ALL RIGHT.
THERE YOU HAVE IT.
THE PRESIDENT WRAPPING UP.
AND WE START TONIGHT WITH
BREAKING NEWS ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT FIGHTING BACK AFTER
TWO PLUS YEARS OF NOTHING BUT
COMPLETE AND UTTER COOPERATION.
1.5 MILLION DOCUMENTS HANDED
OVER.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THE
WHITE HOUSE ENCOURAGED TO
COOPERATE AND SPEAK WITH MUELLER
AND CONGRESS.
NOT ONE TIME DID THE TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE INVOKE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
NOT ONCE!
EVEN WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL WHICH
TO ME UNFATHOMABLE DONE AGAIN
WITH HILLARY'S ATTORNEY.
THE PRESIDENT SAYING ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH, TODAY, THE PRESIDENT DID
FINALLY SAY ENOUGH IS ENOUGH BY
EXERTING EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
OVER ALL ASPECTS OF THE MUELLER
REPORT IN THE WHITE HOUSE
ORDERED FORMER COUNSEL DON
MCGAHN FROM TESTIFYING BEFORE
CONGRESS BEAR THEY ALREADY HAD
30 HOURS.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR IS
REFUSING TO BE INTERROGATED NOT
BY THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTE
COMMITTEE, BY THEIR STAFF.
FOR THE 2006 YEARS OF THAT
COMMITTEE, NOT ONE TIME HAS THAT
EVER HAPPENED.
THE ATTORNEYS GENERAL SAYS IT'S
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN NOW.
THE ENDLESS STREAMS ARE NOW
BEING REJECTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION BE IN THE HUNT IS
OVER, THE DEMOCRATS LOST, AND
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE DOING
IS NOTHING BUT RADICAL REVENGE
BORN OUT OF A MASS PSYCHOTIC
RAGE AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
BY THE WAY, FOUR SEPARATE
INDEPENDENT -- FOUR!
THEY HAVE AN IRRATIONAL
INABILITY TO ACCEPT FOUR
INDEPENDENT RESULTS, THE
NINE-MONTH FBI
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION?
NO, PETER STRZOK, NO THERE
THERE.
WE HAVE NOTHING.
LISA PAGE SAID TO IT WE HAVE THE
HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATION.
NO COLLUSION.
NO CONSPIRACY.
NO COOPERATION WITH RUSSIA.
THE BIPARTISAN SENATE
INVESTIGATIONS.
THE 20 MONTH MUELLER WITCH HUNT.
ALL DETERMINING THE SAME THING.
NO COLLUSION, NO OBSTRUCTION.
DOES CONGRESS CARE ONE IOTA HOW
MUCH THIS IS COSTING IN LEGAL
FEES?
AND FOR WHAT?
WHAT ABOUT EVERY SINGLE PERSON
THAT HAD BEEN CALLED BEFORE THE
COMMITTEES, CALLED BEFORE
MUELLER?
THEY ALL HAVE TO PAY FOR
LAWYERS.
LAWYERS IN WASHINGTON, D.C., CAN
BE AS MUCH AS A THOUSAND DOLLARS
AN HOUR!
NOW THEY ARE GOING TO BE CALLED
IN TO ASK THE SAME QUESTIONS,
FOURTH, FIFTH, SIXTH TIME?
THIS IS NOTHING BUT HARASSMENT
AND ABUSE OF POWER.
AND FRANKLY, A BRAND-NEW
TAXPAYER-FUNDED WITCH HUNT
DESIGNED TO SMEAR THE DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND ANYBODY THAT
HAS DARED TO ENTER HIS ORBIT IN
SUPPORT.
THAT'S WHY TONIGHT WE TURN TO
THE WASHINGTON SWAMP, 19 TERM
CONGRESSMAN JERRY NADLER WASTING
VALUABLE TIME, RESOURCES TO
CONTINUE TO PROLONG AND CONTINUE
TO PUSH AND DEBUNK HOPES OF
CONSPIRACY, THE DESPERATION
WREAKS AN EFFORT TO BE TOTALLY
TRANSPARENT, THE ETERNAL
GENERAL GAVE NADLER AND 11 OTHER
SENIOR LAWMAKERS ACCESS TO A
TOTALLY UNREDACTED VERSION OF
THE MUELLER REPORT.
THAT INCLUDED EVERYTHING EXCEPT
GRAND JURY MATERIAL.
.1% WAS HANDED OVER BECAUSE
THAT'S ILLEGAL.
YOU'VE GOT TO KEEP IN MIND THAT
THIS IS BECAUSE OF A LAW THAT
NADLER SUPPORTED IN THE 1990s.
BARR WAS UNDER NO OBLIGATION
BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE NADLER
WANTED THE LAW THIS WAY BUT
DIDN'T EVEN WANT THE STARR
REPORT TO BE SEEN BY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEN THEY CHANGE THE LAW.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS NO
OBLIGATION TO RELEASE ONE WORD
OF THE MUELLER REPORT.
BUT STILL, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
BARR, WELL, UNREDACTED
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION, ONGOING
CASE MATERIALS, PUBLICLY
WITHHELD CONTENT THAT MIGHT
REVEAL SOURCES AND METHODS, THE
WHOLE ENTIRE COUNTRY WAS ABLE TO
SEE.
THE JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN NADLER
REFUSED TO TAKE THE TIME AND SEE
THE UNREDACTED VERSION.
GO SEE THE WHOLE THING!
INSTEAD TODAY, CHAIRMAN NADLER'S
CIRCUS VOTED TO HOLD THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS.
ACCORDING TO NADLER, THIS IS ALL
ABOUT BARR'S DECISION TO DEFY
HIS SUBPOENA THAT DEMANDED THE
UNRETRACTED SCREEN AND REPORT BE
RELEASED TO THE FULL COMMITTEE.
THE RANKING COMMITTEE MEMBER
DOUG COLLINS POINTED OUT THAT A
SUBPOENA WAS "A POWERFUL AND
COURSE OF TOOL ONLY NEED TO BE
USED WHEN ATTEMPTS TO REACH AN
ACCOMMODATION WITH THE WITNESS
HAVE REACHED AN IMPASSE."
DURING THE HEARING, CHAIRMAN
NADLER ON HIS HIGH HORSE IN A
CIRCUS COMMITTEE, HE SAID THE
SUBPOENA WAS MERELY INTENDED TO
START A DIALOGUE WITH BARR'S
OFFICE.
THAT'S NEW.
LET'S START A DIALOGUE.
WE ARE GOING TO SUBPOENA YOU AND
HAVE OTHERS MEMBER THREATEN THE
SERGEANT OF ARMS TO PUT YOU IN
CUFFS AND DRAG YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE.
TAKE A LOOK.
SPEAK OF THE SUBPOENA IS WRITTEN
AS THE BEGINNING OF A DIALOGUE
PROCESS.
A BEGINNING OF A PROCESS TO TALK
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND ULTIMATELY TO GO TO COURT.
BUT IT'S DESIGNED TO BE THE
FOUNDATION OF A DIALOGUE AND
IT'S NOT DESIGNED TO FORCE OUR
HAND IN WHAT WE INSIST ON IN
COURT.
>> Sean: THIS IS NOT THE FIRST
TIME THAT NADLER AND HIS CIRCUS
HAS BEEN CAUGHT TOTALLY AND
COMPLETELY CONTRADICTING
HIMSELF.
NADLER HAS ONE SET OF STANDARDS
FOR HIS GOOD FRIEND
BILL CLINTON -- REMEMBER HIM?
THE STARR REPORT LISTED 11
SEPARATE FELONIES COMMITTED BY
CLINTON.
HE LOST HIS PRACTICE, HIS
LICENSE TO PRACTICE LAW!
HE DID PAY PAULA JONES ALMOST A
MILLION DOLLARS!
YEAH, HE WAS IMPEACHED.
YET NADLER HAS A WHOLE OTHER
STANDARD FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
DEMOCRATS CARE ABOUT COLLUSION,
BUT NOT IF IT'S UKRAINE AND
HILLARY.
THEY CARE ABOUT OBSTRUCTION BUT
NOT HILLARY AND HER LEANING
SUBPOENA EMAILS, 33,000        3
SUBPOENA EMAILS, 33,000        ,
SUBPOENA EMAILS, 33,000        E
SUBPOENA EMAILS, 33,000        D
SUBPOENA EMAILS, 33,000        S
BEEN IN HAMMERS, SIM CARDS
REMOVED.
ONLY FOR A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT,
CAVANAGH, NOT FOR THE
COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA OF
VIRGINIA
COMMONWEALTH GOVERNOR OF
VIRGINIA.
>> A CULMINATION OF THREE MONTHS
OF REQUEST, NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE COMPLETE UNREDACTED REPORT
BY SPECIAL COUNSEL MUELLER.
>> PERHAPS THE RANKING JUDICIARY
MEMBER IS GOING TO HAVE TO GO
OVER THIS MATERIAL, THE 400-500
PAGES IN THE REPORT TO DETERMINE
WHAT IS FIT FOR RELEASE AND WHAT
IS A MATTER OF DECENCY AND
PROTECTING PEOPLE'S PRIVACY
RIGHTS, PEOPLE WHO MAY BE
TOTALLY INNOCENT, PARTIES THAT
MUST NOT BE RELEASED AT ALL.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE?
>> YES, I DO.
IT'S VERY CLEAR THE PRESIDENT
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
SPEAK WE MUST
>> EXCEPT TO DEFEND OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL LIBERTIES AGAINST
A DIRE THREAT.
>> WE HAVE TO PROTECT THE RULE
OF LAW, AND THAT MEANS WE HAVE
TO INVESTIGATE AND HOLD HEARINGS
AND LAYOUT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IF THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
INVOLVED OF ABUSES OF POWER OR
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
HEARD THE ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT AND THEY
OVERWHELMINGLY OPPOSE IMPEACHING
HIM.
THEY ELECTED PRESIDENT CLINTON,
THEY STILL SUPPORT HIM.
THEY HAVE NO RIGHT TO OVERTURN
THE CONSIDERED JUDGMENT OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Sean: JUST A PHONE
HYPOCRITE BUT HIS SHIFT IN THE
OPINION IS NOT AN EXERCISE IN
ANTITRUST VITRIOLIC HAVE POCKETS
THREE.
THIS CURRENT FISHING EXHIBITION
IS MORE THAN A SIMPLE CASE OF
TRUMP HATE RAGE TO RAGE'S
SYNDROME.
DEMOCRATS FEAR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL CAUGHT
RED-HANDED, CONCOCTING,
PERPETUATING A MASSIVE FRAUD.
THIS IS WHAT'S UNDERLYING THE
FEAR AND THE HATRED IN THE
ATTACKS OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL EXPOSE
THEIR HOAX, THE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, WHAT REALLY HAPPENED.
IT SCARES THE LIVING DAYLIGHTS
OUT OF THEM.
BECAUSE HE'S GOING TO